we are taking phone calls at 6 1 7 8 3 0
47 50 I want to go next to Aaron from
New Jersey who last time he called
described himself as a die-hard Biden
fan this is someone I definitely want to
talk to Aaron from New Jersey what's
going on are you still a die-hard Biden
fan I do but thanks for taking my call
yeah yes I am actually
Wow as a black man I kind of feel like
that's my only option really only a
viable option for someone like me okay
hold on Aaron let's not do you're saying
things that we want to explore what
policy of Biden's makes it so obvious to
you as a black man that he is the
candidate for you and no one else could
be I'm not saying that as policy based
but um I think that um in what we have a
certain amount of respect for Barack
Obama that we like what would he want I
think that respecting his legacy I think
that Biden would be the appropriate
candidate for that what evidence do you
have that Obama thinks that black people
would be best off voting for Biden
I think that just the connection that
they have they're kind of synonymous
with each other now I know maybe not
everyone sees that in terms of policy
but I know that when I think of Biden I
think of Obama okay all right so I'm
hearing you Aaron's say that it's
Biden's association with Obama that
makes him the only choice for you I know
you said it's not necessarily about
policy is there any policy you can point
to of Joe Biden's that makes you believe
he will be the best candidate for black
Americans no but I think I do know what
appeals to us oh well you told me that
you thought you told me I mean well I
mean probe policy perspective which is
what you're asking about and that is
that you know what we have right now and
what I think Bernie and Elizabeth worm
would do is they would go to the extreme
but you know from these past two two and
a half years or so I just want to get my
main man Joseph in there so I don't have
to think about politics anymore you know
I know he's not going to rock the boat I
don't want to have to think about
politics or guiding like Aaron but if I
may Erin what policy you mentioned that
you know Bernie Warren extreme what
would be an example of an extreme policy
that as a black American you'd be
worried about from Bernie or Warren well
shaking up health care I don't have to
think about that you know maybe what we
have now is an ideal but like I don't
want to have to worry about like things
that I asked to get involved in or
things that are actually going to affect
me in a way that you know everything
right now works pretty alright so hold
on if if so if someone came forward and
said hey so what do you have insurance
through an employer now or what's your
insurance situation well right now I'm
still on my parent's insurance I'm 26
I'm going to get my own pretty soon guys
I'm 25 actually so you know I don't know
if you know this but when you when you
in a couple years you will have to
either buy in
pterence which could cost you know many
hundreds of dollars per month or you
will have to get a job and when you get
that job they will give you options and
you will be able to say okay I get to
pay one-third of the total and they will
pay two-thirds if they're extremely
generous
what is the plan cover but what is the
deductible doesn't it sound simpler to
just be able to say oh I'm now 26 I'm
off my parent's insurance now I just get
Medicare for all doesn't that sound
simpler possibly but I think it's a
harder sell to whom because like I think
to the general American who's not really
in the weeds on politics okay so that's
maybe a messaging issue that's maybe a
messaging issue but you can it sounds
like you're agreeing that rather than
having to say what's my maximum
out-of-pocket with this plan and can I
afford the 180 a month that would be my
contribution just having Medicare for
all when you turn 26 you agree it's
simpler you're saying though that it's
maybe not been messaged correctly that
could be the case yeah all right Aaron
very good the phone call I am you know a
little bit concerned about what you're
telling me I'm not gonna lie but I do
appreciate you talking to me
oh thanks no problem Michael very good
all right we'll talk to you soon